اهلا بك اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
نتواجد على متن سفينه جلاله الملك ابها
وهي اخر سفن الخاصه الاول التي خصصت
لعمليات الاجلاء من السودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده على متنها 37 شخص
جنسيات متعدده بمقدمتها الجنسيه
الاماراتيه والقطريه وكذلك الجنسيه
وغيرها من الجنسيات العربيه وغير العربيه
نتحدث عن 37 شخص وهي الدفعه الاخيره من
158 شخص تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم برا الى
بورت سودان ومن ثم بحرا الى مدينه جده
وتحديدا في قاعده الملكه فيصل البحريه هنا
في جده نتحدث عن عمليات جلاء تمت بعمليات
بكل يسر وسهوله من خلال تنسيق عالي بين
قطاعات حكوميه عده وبين السفاره السعوديه
وقوات البحريه السعوديه وكذلك وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه لتحدث عن واحد وتسعين
السعودي من ضمن المائه 158
شخص تم اجلاهم اكثر من 11 جنسيه باعمار
مختلفه من سنه ثلاثه اشهر الى السن خمسه
وسبعين يتحدث عن عائلات وكبار سن وكذلك
شباب نتحدث على انه تم التعامل معهم
واستقبالهم فور وصولهم الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في جده تم تقديم كافه
الخدمات اللوجستيه والصحيه والاعاشيه ومن
ثم انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم
من قبل المديريه عامه للجوازات الجمارك
واخيرا تم نقلهم عبر حافلات مخصصه الى
اربعه فنادق في جده لياخذون قسطا من
الراحه وانتهاء عمليات التسكين لتواد حدث
على وجود تواجد امني كبير من قبل قائد
المنطقه وكذلك عدد من القطاعات الامنيه
وممثل لوزاره الخارجيه واهالي من تم
اجلائهم وكذلك عدد من القناصل الخليجيين
والعربيين المتواجدين في جده التي تم
استقبال رعاياهم والتاكد من سلامتهم
وصحتهم تم تخصيص مركبات الاسعاف وطاقم
الطبي للتاكد من سلامتهم فورا او وصولهم
ولله الحمد لم تسجل اي حالات اصابات لهم
وهم يتمتعون بالصحه والعافيه
الملك فيصل البحريه في جده وبالفعل تم
وصول جميع الرعايه الذين تم نقلهم عبر هذه
السفينه وهم الان في طريقهم الى الفنادق
في جده للاستراحه ثم بعد ذلك الانطلاق
منها الى بلدانهم اليس كذلك
بالفعل خصصت القوات البحريه خمسه سفن
اربعه منها هي خاصه بعمليات الاجلاء
والخامسه كانت هي خاصه بعمليات التموين
جميعها وصلت منذ ساعات مبكره وهذه هي
السفينه الاخيره وهي السفينه جلاله الملك
ابها وهي السفير الاخيره الخاصه بعمليه
النقل
وجلاء الرعايه نتحدث 158 شخص وصلوا جميعهم
الى مدينه جده وتحديدا في قاعه الملك فيصل
البحريه ونتواجد الان على متن السفينه
الاخيره الخاصه بعمليات الاجلاء نتحدث انه
وصلت تباعا بينهما ما يقارب الخمسه
واربعين دقيقه عمليه نقل تمت وفق تنظيم
ووفق تنسيقات عاليه بين الحكومه السعوديه
وعدد من الجهات هنالك في الخرطوم لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات